[Music]
my name is parker joe and i'm with
social services
[Music]
i need police and paramedics
[Music]
i get a female doa
i'm your social worker you got a
daughter who needs to get to school all
the time
stop crying into my family i'm trying to
keep ashley from being taken away from
you
i didn't know you're getting out today
dahlia
you're the man who's been looking after
my family huh i'm back
i'd love nothing more than have to come
by here anymore prodigal son is home
caught some chatter on the inside that
might be a real score take care of
business
we're going in there for the money and
the drugs
i'm worried about ashley i'm also
concerned for
cops came to you me tell me this isn't
happening again
[Music]
you think you could do a big favor for
dad
[Music]
this happened here because to you you've
got the cartel after all of us
why are you even helping us no one
helped me when i needed it most
they're in trouble i'm in trouble
i've seen so many families the clips
that they're about to follow from
and there's nothing i can do to stop it
you actually
can help people you have an opportunity
to get something done
[Music]
i don't have to work for someone
if this was your family what would you
[Music]
do
[Music]
you